this next song is called in the kitchen
um contrary to popular belief bisexual
people are real
um and being bisexual means that you can
have girlfriends and boyfriends
um I know I know minds are exploding
pigs are flying it's crazy
um that being said I did have a
boyfriend once I did he was a
dud
um but I wrote this great song out of it
I think and so now I just I profit off
of the pain and
um you know
his parents got divorced and I'm
chilling so
um this is in the kitchen
my heart hits the floor cause it's you
that I'm missing still see the vision of
us
[Music]
and you say please
foreign
[Music]
but I'm too scared to delete
yours
everyone knows you could have at least
[Music]
so don't try this at home
the couch that we sat on back in New
York has made its way three thousand
miles away and these pillow's been
talking
[Music]
to you told me you love me two weeks
[Applause]
cause now it's just me and a hundred
square feet of Bitter Sweet Memories
Melody
is trying to love us to enemies
[Music]
song Jesus
food
[Applause]
it's not done don't try this at home
[Music]
in a Funny How Time Shows you you know
nothing
cause I used to love you but now you're
dead to me
strangers
the enemies
foreign